In today's video,
we have gone all the way
to Canada to see the world's
most uncomfortable bed,
and see if it's even
possible to sleep in it.
[Music]
Hey guys, we're in Canada.
That's right.
Now, a while ago,
you may have seen
I built a big bed,
and that was trying to make
something really comfortable.
Today, we are trying something
that's a little bit different.
In fact, it's kind
of the opposite.
This is the location
of the world's most
uncomfortable bed,
which was built around real-life
experiences of those living
with severe eczema to help
give people a sense
of what it's like to live
with this disease.
The bed is in one
of the rooms back here.
We need to go check it out,
see what makes
it so uncomfortable,
and then one of us is going
to have to put it to the test.
Like a real test.
We've heard a lot
about this bed.
I'm very curious to know
what makes it so uncomfortable,
and how it was
even put together.
Let's find out.
Ready for this?
We'll find out.
Because I'm not.
Oh, no.
I have to go.
It's not exactly thousand
thread count Egyptian cotton.
Got a lovely carpet here,
and by carpet,
I mean like doormat
for scrubbing your shoes off.
Oh my God.
The table is sandpaper.
That's like 36 grit sandpa--
Ow, an actual cactus.
I don't know
what I'm sitting on right now,
but I don't enjoy it.
These are brillo pads.
I sat down to try
and delay the fact
that I have to get
near that bed.
But this was also
a terrible choice.
How is this--
I want to try it too.
Oh, no.
No, you don't actually.
You don't.
Okay, I'm going to try
out the terrible chair.
I'm with jeans and a shirt on.
It's not terrible.
We wear different jeans, Nate.
With my jeans,
it's not terrible.
It looks durable.
From what I've seen so far,
the most comforting part about
this room is the Wi-Fi password.
So...
Like seriously, this,
I think is also a rug
for scraping your shoes.
That a good pillow sound.
I don't know,
but when I just want
to push myself up,
there's something disturbingly
lumpy in this blanket.
This is not a pillow.
Wait.
This is bundles
of crumpled up paper.
Pillow fight.
The worst pillow fight ever.
The scratchy part is
not the part I don't like.
It's like slimy.
It's like kind of sticky.
Do you feel that?
Yeah.
Why is it--
I think that's just
like whatever they add
in it to get the fibers
to bind together.
Because this material I think is
like you use it for putting
like under plants
and stuff to absorb water.
This is just a solid,
solid wood bed frame--
Okay.
Is this--
I think that's it.
That's it.
That's the bottom sheet.
And there's just...
Oh, and it's just 2x4's.
Well, that's--
>> Well, yeah, but...
>> That's supportive.
You know at the end
of a long day,
>> all you want is just to flop on your bed.
>> Fall on your bed.
Don't hurt yourself.
Imagine the itchiest,
scratchiest thing
you've ever touched.
Now, imagine trying
to sleep in it.
Never gone camping,
and your sleeping bag
on the 10th floor was on a rock?
There's something
like 20 of those.
Oh, I want to try walking
on our little carpet here.
Boy, waking up in the morning
and walk on that would really
make you want to go back to bed
if your bed didn't suck so much.
Here's the thing.
I think the bed needs
a proper test.
It does.
Who gets to test it out?
There's only one fair
way to decide this.
It's true.
Okay.
That's one.
One.
It's one.
Best 2 out of 3.
I only need one more.
Okay.
Shoot!
No.
It's--
It looks-- I'm sure
it's really comfortable.
This is the worst bedspread.
It's so heavy.
But that just drives
the itchiness down
into you more.
[Music]
That's awful.
Oh boy.
Ow!
Turning is the worst,
because then you're
actually like rubbing
your skin against it.
Like if you just don't move.
I mean, it's
still not comfortable,
but it's like not the worst.
But then you try
and turn over,
and it's just like--
That's the worst thing?
Not sleeping in it for a night.
That's the worst part,
turning in it.
Okay.
That was terrible.
I'm gonna go like get
a massage or something.
You have fun though.
Why are you going to suffer
through sleeping in this bed?
What's the reasoning
behind this?
Okay guys, the real answer
is this bed was made by
Atopic Dermatitis Revealed.
Their entire goal is
basically to bring awareness
about atopic dermatitis,
which is better known as eczema,
and that affects so many people
you wouldn't even believe.
In fact, I had it
when I was little.
It's incredibly uncomfortable.
It makes sleeping
nearly impossible
when it's bad.
It's itchy.
It can be sore.
It causes rashes,
and it's-- It's awful.
And so they made the world's
most uncomfortable bed
to basically simulate what
a night is like trying to sleep
when you have atopic dermatitis.
So we've got the itchiness,
we've got the discomfort,
we've got--
I swear I felt heating
at some point.
There was--
There was absolutely--
I think there might be--
It feels like it's cooling down.
But we are on top rather--.
Yes, we are.
But yeah, no.
It's doormat that
we're sleeping on.
Because your skin gets hot.
When it-- I mean,
when you get a rash, of course,
it's the skin irritant.
So your skin warms up.
I was going to say
I can't explain
how uncomfortable it is,
but I'm sure lots
of you do know.
Not to mention,
that uncomfortable it can last
throughout the entire day too.
Guys, if you suffer
from extreme eczema
or atopic dermatitis,
talk to your doctor.
There are treatment
options available.
Okay, best 2 out of 3,
out of the best 2 out of 3.
Nope.
You lost.
Good night, Nate.
Okay. Have fun.
The bed's hot again.
I hate this.
And then, it's so lumpy.
Okay.
I can just--
Just gonna...
[Music]
Well, good night, Mark.
Good night.
[Music]
Okay, guys, I am trying here.
I have been in this bed
for an hour now,
and I can't sleep.
This is ridiculous.
I am itchy.
I am scratchy.
I don't know if this is
like a rash forming
from me scratching
or the bed itself.
But this is a nightmare.
I don't know
who designed this,
but you're right.
This is the world's
most uncomfortable bed.
We're gonna try the carpet.
Let me see
if this is any better.
Nope.
Here I am again.
Just me in my [inaudible].
Also, with the size
of the lumps under me,
like no matter
where you turn or try this,
it just gets worse and worse.
It's--
I don't--
It's digging into my spine
and my everything.
There's no sleeping in this bed.
I had headphones in.
And then this voice started.
I really hope you can hear that,
because that's the
creepiest thing ever.
No, I'm done.
[Music]
Hello.
How's--
I'm sorry.
I'm just taking a nap
on this super
comfortable couch out here.
How's--
Did you fall asleep?
What's the worst part so far?
Oh, the worst part.
You'd like to know what
the worst part is so far?
Like the absolute worst part?
Imagine that you
almost fall asleep, right?
And then you don't.
And then imagine a voice
suddenly talking to you
from the darkness.
Oh, there's voices?
Sounds really fun.
Well, have a good night.
Okay, so I know we've joked
around a bit about this now,
but this bed is actually
super itchy and uncomfortable.
I can't even begin
to imagine what it would be
like to experience this
every single night.
So, let's see how things
are going in there.
What's up?
You--
You give up yet?
Yes.
You don't look like you've
been asleep very much.
I'm not talking to you anymore.
Okay.
Silent treatment.
That's--
Yeah.
I'm done.
Tap.
I'm going to be a mess
for a long time.
I'm itchy and I'm tired.
So hearing voices, huh?
That thing talks to you.
There's a speaker setup.
Oh, so we're looking
at the list of things done.
There's a list?
They gave us a list of--
You didn't share it with me.
I learned this recently.
And in addition,
we will have a hidden speaker
with subconscious audio playing
throughout the night.
So there you go.
That was because
they had a patient
that mentioned she heard inner
voices as sort of a side effect
of her condition.
So yeah, here you go.
Delightful, huh?
Your turn.
It's time to go.
Thanks again to
Atopic Dermatitis Revealed
for sponsoring this video,
and letting us try
this thing out.
It's a very
interesting experience,
learning what people
are suffering from who are going
through atopic dermatitis
or severe eczema.
Talk to your doctor
or dermatologist.
Guys, that's all for today.
But you know,
we've always got more
for you to see.
The box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next up.
And hit this bomb
here in the middle
so you'll be subscribe
to the channel.
That way, you're never miss
out on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring the bell,
so you get the
notification about it.
We'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.